one of the things that news stations are
supposed to do is that you're not
supposed to use bogus pictures or video
for reports and Fox News has been caught
doing exactly that this has to do with
the Seattle Capitol Hill autonomous zone
abbreviated or of the acronym is Chas CH
AZ which has sort of formed in the
aftermath of the nationwide protests of
late and this is one of the clearest and
most undeniable violations of just basic
journalistic ethical standards that you
can imagine on Friday they were of
course running stories constantly on
their website about the Chazz this is an
area near Seattle's Capitol Hill where
protesters took over a few blocks after
police left the area and for much of the
day Fox News's web site was running
pictures of a guy with a long gun some
kind of protective vest a beanie and a
green mask standing in front of an Old
Navy with the window smashed out now
this was a completely fabricated what we
would call a collage image this scene
that was pictured on the Fox News
website didn't happen it was a
combination of a Getty image photo of a
guy with a gun who was at the pro set
protest zone on June 10th meaning last
Wednesday with an image from last month
of a smashed window and the entire
collage was completely and totally fake
now this wasn't just one fake image they
used another one had the same gunman
with the green mask with the long gun
appearing to stand at the start of the
CH as sort of placing him almost like he
was an armed sentry to that area now
think what you want about the Chazz
the guy in the green mask was not
actually doing what the pictures suggest
that he was doing it was totally and
completely fake these were doctored
images when the Seattle Times told Fox
News Fox News quietly pulled the
pictures when they were pressed by email
they said we have replaced our photo
illustration with the clearly delineated
images of a gunman and a shattered
storefront both of which were taken this
week in Seattle's autonomous zone except
that explanation is also untrue
because the gunmen photo was taken on
June 10th the storefront image with the
broken window was from May 30th so it
was not taken from this week this week
being last week but this still isn't the
full story for a while on Fox News's web
site there was an image of a building
burning right above a bunch of stories
about protests in Seattle remember that
Friday was June 12th the stories about
Seattle that with all of the stories
below the image are about Seattle and
yet the picture that they're showing was
from st. Paul Minnesota two weeks prior
in May totally fake fabricated
narratives per the Seattle Times on
Saturday Fox apologized in an editor's
note posted saying that the home page
photos did not clearly delineate the
splicing together of multiple images
from different locations and that they
regret that these errors took place so
you can disagree about the capitol hill
autonomous zone the Chazz
it is mostly peaceful it's mostly
artists painting murals and the like but
there have been bad actors no question
people showing up with guns causing more
unrest but this Fox want to generate
more unrest by showing doctored photos
the answer is yes they do that's exactly
what they want to do or they simply
don't care about the truth of the
situation which is also possible and
also not good but understand that they
ran this stuff on their website for
hours and hours they got caught and the
next day oops sorry and that's it and
everybody forgets about it and moves on
zoom out and look at the last three
months we've had distorted lies about
testing fed to us for weeks by the
president and repeated by Fox News until
they just stopped talking about testing
altogether because that wasn't
convenient we had these distorted
unemployment numbers Oh with
unemployment down to thirteen point
three footnote it's really sixteen point
three used by Trump and Fox News in a
sort of self congratulatory tour fake
descriptions of protests as heavily
riddled with an Tifa not true as heavily
violent not
and here they're adding to that with
fake doctored pictures from protests
from a range that is actually multiple
weeks in multiple places presented as
here's one discrete thing that took
place in Seattle it's propaganda this is
how propaganda works and the Trump
administration and Fox News and OAM and
other right wing websites that I don't
even want a name are working together to
spread this stuff and we've got to make
sure we don't allow it to